>> Chris: DAVID SPUNT
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
DAVID, THANK YOU.
JOIN US NOW, FORMER CDC DIRECTOR
DR. TOM FRIEDEN.
DOCTOR, I WANT TO START WITH THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS THESE PAST
FEW WEEKS.
THERE WAS ON FRIDAY MORE THAN
45,000 NEW CASES, A NEW SINGLE
DAY HIGH FOR OUR COUNTRY.
13 STATES SET RECORD HIGHS FOR
THE SEVEN DAY AVERAGE, NEW
CASES.
BUT VICE PRESIDENT PENCE SAID
THIS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN MADE TRULY
REMARKABLE PROGRESS.
IN MOVING OUR NATION FORWARD.
WE’VE ALL SEEN THE ENCOURAGING
NEWS AS WE OPEN UP AMERICA AGAIN
AGAIN.
>> Chris: DOCTOR, ARE WE
MAKING TRULY REMARKABLE
PROGRESS, AND IS THAT THE RIGHT
MESSAGE TO BE SENDING TO THE
NATION AT THIS MOMENT?
>> Dr. Frieden: WELL, THERE’S
NO DOUBT WE’RE DOING MORE
TESTING, OUR HOSPITALS ARE
BETTER PREPARED, BUT THERE’S
ALSO NO DOUBT THAT THE VIRUS HAS
THE UPPER HAND.
THIS VIRUS IS NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY ON ITS OWN.
WE HAVE TO STOP IT AND ONLY WE
CAN DO THAT BY WORKING TOGETHER.
WE ARE ALL SICK AND TIRED OF
STAYING HOME, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE VIRUS IS NOT TIRED OF MAKING
US SICK AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING,
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTHERN STATES,
BUT IN MOST PARTS OF THE U.S.,
IS THIS VIRUS INCREASING AND IN
SOME STATES INCREASING
EXPLOSIVELY.
>> Chris: LET ME DRILL DOWN ON
THAT, HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THE NEW
SURGEON CASES, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SOUTH AND THE WEST IMPACTED SOME
STATES IN THOSE REGIONS, DID
THEY OPEN UP TOO SOON, WE OPEN
TOO SOON AND WITHOUT ENOUGH
RESTRICTIONS?
>> Dr. Frieden: AS I SAID TO
YOU SIX WEEKS AGO TODAY, THIS IS
GOING TO BACKFIRE.
IF WE ARE MOVING TOO FAST.
IF YOU OPEN WHEN CASES ARE STILL
INCREASING, AS MANY STATES DID,
IT’S LIKE LEANING INTO A LEFT
HOOK.
THEY’RE GOING TO GET HIT HARD
AND THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING.
WHEN WE SEE ARIZONA, TEXAS,
FLORIDA, SOUTH CAROLINA, THEY
ARE CURRENTLY IN A RAPID UPSWING
AND SAD TO SAY, THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE FOR WEEKS.
BECAUSE THE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
THAT THEY’RE IMPLEMENTING NOW
WILL ONLY TAKE EFFECT -- YOU
WON’T SEE IT FOR ANOTHER FEW
WEEKS, SO WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
FEW MORE WEEKS OF INCREASES IN
ALL LIKELIHOOD IN SEVERAL STATES
STATES.
THERE’S SOME COMFORT IN THE FACT
THAT IT’S YOUNGER PEOPLE, BUT
WHAT STARTS IN THE YOUNG DOESN’T
STAY IN THE YOUNG.
YOUNGER PEOPLE HAVE PARENTS,
UNCLES, NEPHEWS, THEY GO OUT TO
PLACES TO BUY FOOD AND WE ARE
GOING TO SEE INCREASING SPREAD.
THAT’S WHY THE THREE Ws ARE SO
IMPORTANT, WEAR A MASK, WASH
YOUR HANDS OR YOU SANITIZER, AND
WATCH HER DISTANCE.
THERE SOMETHING EVERYONE CAN DO.
WE ARE REALLY ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND IF WE WORK TOGETHER
WE CAN HELP CONTROL THE VIRUS
AND GET OUR ECONOMY BACK.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH ISSUES
ARE NOT GETTING IN THE WAY OF
OUR RECOVERY, THEY ARE THE ROUTE
TO OUR RECOVERY.
>> Chris: DOCTOR, ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS YOU HEAR IS THAT THE
REASON WE ARE SEEING A SURGE IN
NEW CASES IS BECAUSE WE ARE
SEEING A SURGE IN MORE TESTING.
HERE’S PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THAT
THIS WEEK.
>> WE HAVE MORE CASES BECAUSE WE
DO THE GREATEST TESTING.
IF WE DIDN’T DO TESTING, WE HAVE
NO CASES.
>> Chris: IS THE SEARCH
FUNCTION OF MORE TESTING, OR IS
IT A REFLECTION OF THE FACT THAT
THE VIRUS IS ACTUALLY SPREADING?
>> Dr. Frieden: AS A DOCTOR,
SCIENTIST, AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST, I
CAN TELL YOU WITH 100% CERTAINTY
THAT IN MOST STATES WHERE YOU’RE
SEEING AN INCREASE, IT IS A REAL
INCREASE.
IT IS NOT MORE TESTS, IT IS MORE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AND THE ONE
NUMBER TO LOOK AT THAT’S VERY
IMPORTANT IS THE PERCENT OF
TESTS THAT ARE POSITIVE.
IF THE NUMBER OF CASES, THAT CAN
VARY SOME BECAUSE WE ARE ONLY
DIAGNOSING TEN, 20% OF ALL
CASES.
SO THE NUMBERS YOU’RE SEEING ARE
JUST A REFLECTION, TIP OF THE
ICEBERG OF EVEN MORE SPREAD.
BUT WHERE THE NUMBERS ARE
INCREASING, YOU COULD ARIZONA
WITH NEARLY 1 OUT OF 4 TESTS
POSITIVE AND AT THE SAME TIME
YOU ARE INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
TESTS, I CAN TELL YOU WITH
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY THAT’S
EXPLOSIVE SPREAD OF CORONAVIRUS.
>> Chris: WHILE WE ARE SEEING
THE NUMBER OF CASES EXPLODE, UP
65% IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS, WE
ARE SEEING THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
ACTUALLY DROPPING 27%.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> Dr. Frieden: THERE ARE A
FEW THINGS GOING ON.
FIRST OFF, DEATHS WILL LAG CASES
BY ABOUT A MONTH.
IT TAKES SOME TIME FOR SOMEONE
TO FEEL SICK, GET HOSPITALIZED
AND UNFORTUNATELY DIED.
SECOND, THE CASES DO APPEAR TO
BE IN YOUNGER PEOPLE KNOW IN THE
DEATH RATE IS FAR, FAR FAR LOWER
IN YOUNGER PEOPLE AND OLDER.
BUT AS I SAID EARLIER, WHAT
STARTS IN YOUNG ADULTS, DOESN’T
STAY IN YOUNG ADULTS.
THERE MAY BE A LAG UNTIL WE SEE
CASES.
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT OLDER PEOPLE
ARE SHIELDING THEMSELVES MORE
AND WE ARE ALSO GETTING BETTER
FOR CARING FOR IT.
THE EXPLOSIVE SPREAD IS BEING
FOLLOWED YET BY AN EXPLOSIVE
INCREASE IN DEATHS, BUT WHAT WE
ARE SEEING IN SOME STATES
ALREADY IS A BIG INCREASE IN
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT ADMISSIONS
AND THAT’S A SIGN THAT THIS IS
NOT BENIGN, THIS IS GOING TO
RESULT IN MORE DEATHS.
WE ESTIMATE IN THE NEXT MONTH WE
WILL SEE AT LEAST 15,000 MORE
DEATHS IN THE U.S.
>> Chris: MEANWHILE, THIS HAS
ALL BECOME EVEN MORE OF A
POLITICAL ISSUE, AS EVERYTHING
SEEMS TO BE IN THIS COUNTRY.
76% OF DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THEY
WEAR A MASK, ALL OR MOST OF THE
TIME.
AS COMPARED TO 53% OF
REPUBLICANS AND THIS WEEK, 3,000
YOUNG SUPPORTERS OF THE
PRESIDENT PACKED A CHURCH IN
ARIZONA AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE
SCREEN HERE, ALMOST NONE OF THEM
WEARING MASKS.
HERE’S VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
>> THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON THE
RIGHT TO PEACEFULLY ASSEMBLE IS
ENSHRINED WITH THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND EVEN IN A HEALTH CRISIS,
PEOPLE DON’T FORFEIT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
>> Chris: I’M ASKING OF THIS
IS THE FORMER HEAD OF THE CDC,
ONE OF THE LEADING PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS IN THE COUNTRY.
AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
NOT A MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW, WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU
SEE HUNDREDS, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE CLOSE TOGETHER INDOORS
NOT WEARING MASKS?
>> Dr. Frieden: THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR.
MORE PEOPLE WITH LESS
VENTILATION INDOORS WITH A HIGH
RATE OF CORONAVIRUS, NOT WEARING
MASKS, THAT IS A FORMULA FOR
EXPLOSIVE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
>> Chris: FINALLY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES TO SAY
THAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
VACCINE, HIS WORDS, VERY SOON.
PERHAPS BY BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR.
WHAT IS THE LIKELIHOOD OF THAT,
GIVE US A REALITY CHECK ON ONE
WE CAN REALLY BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT A VACCINE.
>> Dr. Frieden: ALTHOUGH WE
ARE SEEING REALLY ENCOURAGING
PROGRESS, THERE’S NO EVIDENCE
THAT PEOPLE DO GET IMMUNITY THAT
MAY BE PROTECTED, THERE ARE MORE
THAN 100 VACCINE CANDIDATES
BEING EVALUATED, SOME OF THEM
ARE LOOKING GOOD AND SOME
PRELIMINARY STUDIES.
IT’S REALLY HARD TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO MAKE
SURE IT’S SAFE.
THERE’S ALREADY TOO MUCH
SUSPICION ABOUT VACCINES, WE
CAN’T CUT ANY CORNERS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT’S SAFE,
EFFECTIVE, FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT
DOSE, DECIDE WHO’S GOING TO GET
IT FIRST, DEVELOP IT,
MANUFACTURE LARGE QUANTITIES,
GET IT OUT THERE, SET UP SYSTEMS
TO TRACK FOR BAD REACTIONS.
THIS IS NOT A QUICK FIX, IT’S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO -- IT’S
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WE CAN DO TO FIGHT CORONAVIRUS
AND THAT’S WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT
WE HAVE TO IT CAREFULLY.
WE CAN’T CUT ANY CORNERS.
WE MAY HAVE AT NEXT YEAR, BUT
WHAT HAVING IT MEANS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT, IT MEANS THAT PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO START TO HAVE
AVAILABILITY FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, FOR EXAMPLE, BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT’S SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE BEFORE WE PUT IT INTO